y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con este sonido
los indígenas de las diversas
comunidades del ecuador rinden homenaje
al sol a los diversos elementos de la
naturaleza en las festividades sean el
yo la tricas como solsticios equinoccios
y también en los rituales que destacan
elementos de la cosmovisión andina
tengo el gusto de compartir con ustedes
algunos elementos vinculados con
nuestros pueblos originarios del actual
ecuador en relación con los sonidos
cuando hablamos de los primeros
habitantes de nuestro territorio
actualmente conocido como ecuador
estamos hablando más o menos de hace
unos 12.000 años un periodo en el cual
estas personas eran nómadas cazadores
recolectores y producían sonidos con
elementos muy fáciles de conseguir en
primera instancia con su propio cuerpo
que es el primer instrumento sonoro que
utiliza el ser humano
tenemos las palmas con las manos no es
cierto el zapateo y la voz con la cual
podemos ya emitir sonidos comunicarnos y
también compartir nuestras vivencias
interiores y relacionarnos con los demás
existente
luego de que se da cuenta el ser humano
de que su cuerpo es sonoro ya que el
hombre es un animal rítmico empieza a
utilizar elementos de la naturaleza para
producir sonidos no hablemos de
instrumentos musicales porque su
interino es bien occidental sino más
bien de objetos sonoros entonces el ser
humano empieza a utilizar lo que
encuentra la naturaleza piedras que las
golpea y produce ritmos ramas
a los
elementos biológicos como osamentas y
animales con los cuales va construyendo
los primeros objetos sonoros y va
obviamente comunicándose
si hablamos por ejemplo de una falla de
una mandíbula de un burro
encontrada en el campo
con el paso de los años adquiere pues
una consistencia más bien acústica como
para que las piezas dentarias los
molares puedan producir sonidos
[Música]
entonces
y el ser humano tiene la posibilidad de
ir utilizando elementos exteriores a su
cuerpo para enriquecer su mundo sonoro
aquí tenemos otro instrumento también
construido pero con el cráneo de un
venado
un instrumento ritual ístico que
funciona por la insuflación de aire por
la vibración
del viento que puede producir también
sonidos
[Música]
obviamente
los vegetales que encuentra a su
alrededor
sirven como materia prima para construir
otro tipo de instrumentos podríamos
hablar de flautas
horizontales verticales e incluso de
elementos tan sencillos como una hoja de
un árbol que puede también producir
sonidos
bueno se rompen también se les da la
vuelta
[Música]
por plumas
o plumas de diversas aves cuyos tubos
por cierto pueden servir también como
objetos sonoros
esta sería una andada de plumas de
diversas aves tenemos plumas de halcón
plumas de pelícano y también una pluma
que generosamente nos obsequiaron en el
zoológico de baños de ambato por si
acaso de cóndor
entonces si nosotros le damos una
dimensión adecuada a cada una de las
plumas igual que fuera una caña como
carrizo o shade o duda podemos cambiar
la altura de los sonidos
[Música]
otro logo fundamental del ser humano
es utilizar la arcilla
el lodo
o sea mezclar tierra con agua con formar
una masa dúctil cierto que permita a dar
formas que representan en muchos casos
animales por ejemplo una flauta globular
somos lo cierto o aves que son figuras
hornito muertas
y que nos permiten también conseguir
mayor variedad de sonidos
de tal manera que la organología
organología es el conjunto de
instrumentos y el estudio de ellos y la
clasificación de acuerdo a su naturaleza
como aerófonos cordófonos membranófonos
digo van incrementando ya la organología
de los pueblos prehispánicos y
obviamente organizando los sonidos de
tal manera de que ya pueden manejarse lo
que llamaríamos escalas vemos cómo suena
un instrumento de cerámica este es un
instrumento llamado flauta globular su
amorfa tiene la forma de una tortuga
[Risas]
este movimiento de la embocadura u
orificio de insuflación con el cual
producimos los sonidos puede permitirnos
sacar conseguir micro tonos o sea
intervalos menores a los semitonos que
trajeron los europeos con su escalada
día tónica cómo se llama de tal manera
que a través de los estudios de la arc y
musicología llegamos a la hipótesis de
que los pueblos pre incas anteriores a
1.460 más o menos que llegan del sur los
incas y consolidan el tahuantinsuyo digo
los pueblos anteriores a los incas
tenían en nuestro territorio más bien
escalas micro tonales o sea de cuartos y
octavos de tono porque esto no
esto es patrimonio solamente de los
andes en la india se llaman los cruces
que son intervalos mínimos entre sonidos
y con ello se interpretan raras
cánticos
melodías para la alabanza a las deidades
entonces este tipo de instrumentos nos
permiten irnos aproximando hacia una
cosmo audición de los pueblos
originarios
casi siempre escuchamos más bien el
término cosmovisión
que tiene mucho que ver con ese conjunto
de ideas de creencias de visualizaciones
relacionadas con los demás existente que
permiten al ser humano tener un nexo
coherente una forma de comunicarse una
forma de asumir su existencia de acuerdo
al macro y al microcosmos pero quienes
estamos inmersos en la musicología
hablamos y con gusto de una especie de
ardid semántico no porque claro el
microcosmos también sería como un
paraguas que cubre al ala como audición
la cosa audición sería el conjunto de
sonidos de códigos sonoros que los seres
humanos utilizamos para comunicarnos con
los demás existente por ejemplo producir
sonidos onomatopéyicos de la naturaleza
para tratar de atraer a un ave por
ejemplo producir un sonido como el
silbido de un ave o el gorjeo o de
pronto producir un sonido como de viento
para lograr que el guairá el taita wire
el tratamiento pueda apoyarnos en
nuestras actividades no es cierto
entonces por ejemplo este es un
instrumento de cerámica que produce un
sonido como de viento
y de pronto tenemos esta flauta globular
hornito morfa que representa a un ave
que puede tratar de imitar el sonido de
las aves no
[Música]
que nuestros antepasados los seres
originarios de nuestra tierra de nuestro
acta
tuvieron logros importantísimos dentro
del manejo de los instrumentos musicales
son los mestizos
y no solo como decía la persona que
mente se dio con la palabra
cromosomas si no también
tenemos un mestizaje en el caso de la
música un mestizaje sonoro muy amplio
lo que trajeron los europeos obviamente
que el interesante instrumentos muy
evolucionados para la época no es cierto
para el siglo 16
formas musicales interesantes
pasados indígenas
también tenían los suyos
los propios instrumentos tenían sus
propias melodías
los cronistas españoles cuando llegan
estoy dicen a pesar de que esta música
es imperfecta
y tienen música para
jazz y música para las ceremonias en
homenaje al sol y tienen música para el
amor y para
entonces la riqueza órgano lógica de
nuestros pueblos originarios realmente
es inmensa y está mucho por descubrirse
y ojalá nos ayude a subir nuestra
autoestima
procedemos
de grupos humanos llamemos culturas o
civilizaciones con grandes logros dentro
de lo sonoro
de los elementos fundamentales de la
audición andina es la dualidad
presente
en el tema territorial
en el tema sonoro en el tema
gastronómico hay sabores fuertes
masculinos sabores
sutiles
colores masculinos colores femeninos
san blas es hanan san sebastián es un
ring es arriba
y también los instrumentos pueden ser
machos o hembras
y cuando se complementan producen ya
melodías si este es un sonido macho
y este en verano
como las mujeres la voz más aguda y los
varones la voz más grave pero cuando se
juntan
[Música]
[Risas]
y hay instrumentos que en un solo cuerpo
sonoro
tienen el componente macho y hembra por
ejemplo este
gente tiene que detener
t
estéticamente
realmente debe ser manejado con mucha
precisión en este tipo de conferencias
voy solamente
la intervención rindiendo homenaje a
nuestros pueblos originarios
específicamente a una de las culturas
más importantes del período formativo
que es la cultura chorrera
haciendo sonar una réplica de una
botella silbato un instrumento de
cerámica compuesto por dos cuerpos que
funciona con agua si ponemos a un el uno
y le pasamos al otro
produce sonido
encontramos el instrumento de este tipo
en algunas culturas de nuestro planeta
pero lo importante es que los más
antiguos vestigios en el planeta tierra
de este tipo de instrumentos son de la
cultura chorrera
y quiero que terminemos alegres
este es un rico pingüino cañar y un
instrumento que no tiene orificios de
digitación para subir o bajar los
sonidos tapando destapando orificios
sino que sólo con la fuerza con que
sopló cambian los sonidos
[Música]
y homenaje a los pueblos originarios y a
todos los presentes gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o